okay we are back on the Internet's what
does the panel think of Obama's musings
this week about mandatory voting you
have a lot of uninformed people voting
we do now yeah you'll multiply that
number yeah well I don't know about that
because I don't think unless they you
know you write fine in Australia they do
this mandatory it would be a fun that's
what they do they want to have 35 or 40%
of the electorate voting that really did
know something as opposed to 100 percent
just going in and stamping whatever I
mean I think I don't think it's kind of
an American and Ettore voting but we
have to do something we have to make
voter registration easier we probably
should think about moving elections to
the weekends when people aren't one
party I'm not gonna say which one does
not want more the same thing the
Democrats want which is more of our
people to vote unless of yours you guess
what both parties rights but I think
part of being American is exercising
freedom not to vote in the libertarian
in May says you know what if I don't
want to vote that's voting in itself
that's saying the statements and I
shouldn't be wouldn't want to be
mandatory but I'm this is off top my
head but didn't something like 80
percent of the eligible voters vote in
the presidential election of 1960
kennedy-nixon something like 80 percent
no no I think so absolutely not not a me
maybe 66 I think was more than that
let's have a but let's have a bet now if
only the considerably more I want to get
in holy we were living in the future Bob
and that's a way to look stuff like that
up quickly on your phone
% are you including the Chicago votes
because I think 80 is way off and I'm
what do you want to bet Bob who's gonna
pay for dinner tonight
yeah great free turn on me okay I say
it's closer to 60 you say it's closer to
80 right that's the bet
70 is the breaking point house the house
collects on 70 Bob do you think that the
NCAA should pay its student athletes I
think they should be paid a stipend so
that like the average college student
because many of these kids come from
disadvantaged backgrounds they're able
to get through college with more than
just tuition room board books but if you
pay them a salary
you're basically waving the white flag
and saying this is a complete sham
that's all it is which they've allowed
it to become but it is a complete show
yes but if you're saying if universal
okay here's here's something interesting
we were talking about this earlier
things you'd like to hear said on the
air I like March Madness as well as
anybody buzzer beaters and everything
else and it's all terrific but you'll
there every conceivable stat you don't
want to embarrass any individual kid but
you will never find even during a
timeout any talk of the disconnect
between academics and athletics and what
a complete sham this is for so many of
these schools and so many of these kids
if University if university presidents
say when it comes to the revenue
producing sports because lacrosse
players swimmers tennis players actually
graduate at higher rates than the
average student body but if they said we
are going to take control of admissions
for football basketball and maybe in a
few cases women's basketball nobody gets
into this school that couldn't get into
this school plausibly if it didn't have
a basketball a football team now go
coach these guys they end a problem but
they won't do it it's like unilaterally
disarming Bob we have an answer on the
1960 vote
that's why you were smirking 63 wait'll
I order the lobster and the domperidone
Jack is Speaker Boehner working too much
with Democrats and sacrificing a
conservative agenda oh I think you know
it's interesting that the President of
the United States seems to be more
comfortable with the Iranians than he is
with Republicans it's not necessary they
can sit down and work together I feel
like both sides should be talking a lot
more things nothing a Cuban would say
that's certainly not the way calm cool
white people so what do you miss the
most about Congress and what do you miss
the least well I miss the camaraderie I
missed the debate every time I start I
stole a Lincoln bus from it one time on
the HBO show what what it was Stephen
Colbert we went in there as well in the
office apparently yes you normally pay
the office either like a light blue of
beige or white I mean and you get like
what use furniture what is it Illinois
no there's a lot of weird political [ __ ]
in Illinois I mean Fergana vich but what
was his name blog on of it that's he
remember he like he sacrificed his
career so he could buy Mac Michael
Jackson's old [ __ ] Michael Jackson's
cape it is bipartisan yeah in there
three in jail and both parties
we feel good I still want to get in on
the free meal that Bob let's get another
bad guy I can take that now America
Mercedes a Scott Walker just the flavor
of the week or is he a serious national
candidate he could be a flavor of the
month but I mean I do think he's one of
the serious contenders obviously he's up
there with former Florida Governor Jeb
Bush but I think again very yep and in
several states ahead of him and I'll
tell you why because he's the one guy on
your side who is liked by both the
establishment Republican and Marco Rubio
is too though he's liked by the
establishment and the Cuban no but so I
think watch out for Marco Rubio because
I think why do so again walk what I
think Walker brings is that fresh face
which is what we're not seeing with
Hillary Clinton so I think you know she
he's a fresh face yes you look at the
polls
okay don't say fresh like fresh anyway
we've already established your races are
you now being sexist are you saying
fresh-faced like cheese and all no I I'm
not okay because you know here what are
your words in my mouth and yeah we are
very gays can be homophobic trust me I
speak of both of my people don't I make
this
I know of what I said what do you think
about the Dolce and Gabanna scandal now
I mean they're two old Italian guys who
are gay but they're saying like we are
all the Italian guys hey you know what
do we like I don't the old-fashioned way
you put your thing in the vagina you
know disgusting vagina no you put things
in there that I mean they called Elton
John's babies and that was not his
specific but synthetic children right I
think they were at that slide situation
one
it proves that there are stupid and
insensitive gay people just like there
are stupid and insensitive straight
people so my sexual orientation is not
any smarter or more sensitive than
anybody so if they have an old worldview
they're stupid I think their what they
said particularly because it was about
children was stupid and mean and
insensitive because I think that's just
unkind people have been born iv5 million
the first one was 1978 and she had
children the natural way but I think it
was no prob a baby
I'll always four less babies being born
because they do not have horrible bill
that's horrible I'm the mother of five
kids I shouldn't be
that's super selfish in a world in the
rate the birthrate in the United States
is it continues to decrease at least the
slaps are providing some extra kids here
and there well we don't need an Irish
does not have enough research I'll be
indefinite what do you mean come on what
is your problem fingernails on the
blackboard for those there might be a
few Democrats in the audience just a few
genetically modified less water less
fertilizer less land you can feed a
world of nine million people which were
closing in on but we get great
resistance just to have an intelligent
conversation about it and I think that's
part of the solution to the world
population and Monsanto children are not
synthetic
thank you